foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
Let's look ahead at what will happen in
The Following season of House of the
dragon as you all know in the season 1
finale we saw renira's Sons leave
Dragonstone so they could hand deliver
her letter to some of the major houses
of Westeros who she is hoping to win
over on their side unfortunately
renera's younger son lucari's valerion
did not survive the mission not only did
renera lose one of her sons in his
Dragon but she also lost a major Ally in
house Baratheon along with its Bannerman
in my last video I showed you what will
happen during the mission of raniera's
other son Jace when he arrives at the
vale white Harbor and Winterfell not
only does he survive and make it back
home but he also won over these houses
along his way now I want to show you
what will happen immediately after
Rainier found out her son died above
shipbreaker Bay in the season 1 finale
we saw raniera's reaction after Damon
revealed this devastating news this
shocking of event actually unfolds a
little differently in George RR Martin's
novel Fire and Blood now if you read
what George R Martin has written in Fire
and Blood you will see Damon isn't there
when Rainer finds out her son died Damon
actually left Dragonstone on his Dragon
craxis when rhaenyra's Sons left for
their mission as Lou carries was heading
for Storm's end and Jace was on his way
North Damon left with him to go on a
little mission of his own when House of
the dragon's second season begins we
should see him leave Dragonstone for
harrenhal now although harrenhal is in
shambles it's still the largest Castle
in Westeros and its massive curtain wall
still made it incredibly formidable
however aegon the dragon revealed
exactly how vulnerable it is from the
sky as you all know aegon the Conqueror
had balerion the black dread unleashes
dragon fire on harrenhal and Damon knew
he could have his Dragon do the same
with its Lord Lara strong away in King's
Landing harrenhal was but lightly
garrisoned there weren't very many men
here here to defend the castle
especially against the dragon when Damon
arrives on caraxis they immediately
strike their banners having no wish to
suffer the same fate as when aegon
arrived on Valeria on the black dread
harrenhal will now be in the hands of
Damon Targaryen now in addition to the
castle Damon also captured the wealth of
how strong as well as about a dozen
valuable hostages among those was Sir
Simon strong and his grandsons he also
made the small Focus captives along with
a wet nurse who went by the name of
Alice Rivers now I do wonder if we will
see her in House of the Dragon because
George R Martin has a few interesting
things written about this woman we're
not exactly sure who she is and
according to graemeister monkin he says
she is a serving one she dabbles in what
might be magical spells septanus stay
says she is a Woods witch now mushroom
would have us believe she likes to bathe
in the blood of virgins as a way to hold
on to her youth given her last name many
would assume she is a bastard however we
know little of her father and even less
of her mother Grand maester Monken also
says her father is actually Lord Lionel
strong which would make her a natural
half-sister to his son sir Harwin break
bones and Laris the clubfoot mushroom
however swears she is much older in fact
he says she was the wet nurse for Harwin
and Laris not their sister although her
own babies had all been stillborns the
milk that flowed so abundantly from the
breast of Alice Rivers had nourished a
number of babies born of other women at
harrenhal now was she actually a Woods
witch who laid with demons and brought
forth dead children in return for the
knowledge they gave her was she a
simple-minded slattern as septanus stays
firmly believes or was she someone who
worked with some form of magical spells
to bind men to her body and soul either
way she seems very interesting and I do
hope we see her in House of the Dragon
Alice Rivers was at least 40 years of
age during the dance of the dragons that
much is known however once again
mushroom swears she's my much older
everyone does agree that she looks much
younger than her age now whether her
looks were natural or done through some
form of the dark arts no one knows for
sure whatever magic she may have known
did not work on Damon Targaryen for
little was actually heard of her while
Damon held harrenhal the sudden and
bloodless fall of harrenhal was
considered a great victory for Damon
ianera it served as a sharp reminder of
what Damon in his Dragon caraxis are
able to do it also gave renira an
incredible stronghold right in the heart
of Westeros when Damon sent forth his
Call to Arms they rose up all along the
rivers Knights and men at Arms who
remembered the realm's Delight so
beloved of her father there were
hundreds and thousands of men who
buckled on their sword belts and donned
their mail and began to make their way
to harrenhal to fight for viserys's
little girl meanwhile things were
unfolding very differently for renera's
Sons like I said earlier in my last
video I went over what will happen
during Jace's mission and up north now I
want to show you what George R Martin
has written when rainera and Damon finds
out amond and vegar killed lucari's
there is one thing you have to remember
in George RR Martin's novel Fire and
Blood the death of lucarius and his
Dragon was no accident amond and vegar
were out for blood when rhaenyra learns
of this back on Dragonstone she
immediately Falls onto the floor the
little brother Joffrey swore a horrible
oath of Vengeance against aemond one eye
and Lord Baratheon he actually went to
get on his dragon and leave but the sea
snake had to stop him when the Black
Council gathered on Dragonstone they
said and thought of how they would
strike back against their enemy that's
when a raven arrived from harrenhal as
you can see Damon wasn't there when this
happened but when he found out he
immediately sent rhaenyra a raven his
letter only said an eye for an eye a sun
for a son Damon wrote lucari shall be
Avenged let it not be forgotten when he
was younger Damon was loved throughout
the city of King's Landing his face and
laugh was familiar to every horror and
gambler and flea bottom he also still
had a lot of friends who live in the
shadows of the city not to mention many
men within the city watch are still
loyal to him as well now unbeknownst to
King aegon Serato or alicent he even had
allies sitting on the green Council
Damon also had an ace up his sleeve
someone who knew the wine sinks and the
Rats that festered in the shadow of the
red keep as well as he once had and
moved easily through the Shadows of the
city we will see Damon reach out to
massaria by secret ways and they will
set in motion of vicious Vengeance in
flea bottom Damon's former mistress will
find suitable instruments for the
mission one of them had been a sergeant
in the city watch he was big and brutal
and he was thrown out of the city watch
after beating a horde of death while he
was drunk the other man was a rat
catcher in the red key if you have
watched every episode in the first
season then you know they've already
been foreshadowing this in a number of
different scenes we've already seen the
rats all over the red keep now the real
names of these men have been lost to
history however they are remembered as
blood and cheese obviously this rat
catcher knew the red key better than
anyone the hidden doors and all of its
secrets that maegor had built were as
familiar to the rat catcher as the rats
he hunted in the shadows within the red
keep cheese LED blood into the heart of
the castle unseen by any guard now some
say they were after the new king himself
but aegon was with the kingsguard
wherever he went and even cheese knew of
no way in or out of maegor's holdfast
except over the drawbridge that spanned
the dry moat and its formidable iron
spikes the Tower of the hand was less
secure these men crept up through the
walls bypassing any Spearman standing
guard outside the doors serato's rooms
were of no interest to them instead they
slipped into his daughter's Chambers one
floor below Ellison had taken up
residence there after the death of
Osiris when her son aegon moved into
maegor's holdfest with his own wife and
sister Helena once inside cheese bound
and gagged Allison while blood strangled
her bed made then they settled down to
wait for they knew it was the custom of
Helena to bring her children to see
their grandmother Allison every evening
before bed blind to her danger Helena
arrived as dusk was settling over the
castle joined by her three children
joharis and johera were six maalor was
only two as they entered the apartments
Helena was holding his little hand and
calling out her mother's name that's
when blood barred the door and slew
Helena's Guardsmen while Chi snatched up
little mailor scream and you all die
blood told her grace Helena did keep her
calm and is said who are you she
demanded of them we are debt collectors
said she's an eye for an eye a son for a
son we only want one to make thing
things right we won't hurt the rest of
you fine folks not one low hair which
one you want to lose your grace once she
realized what he meant Helena begged
with the men to kill her instead a
wife's not a son said blood it has to be
a boy that's when she's warned Helena to
make a choice soon otherwise blood would
grow bored and rape her little girl you
must decide he said or we will kill them
all on her knees weeping Helena named
her youngest son maelor mayhaps she
thought the boy was too young to
understand or maybe it was because the
older boy jaharis was King aegon's
firstborn son in Heir next in line for
the Iron Throne you hear that little boy
cheese whispered to mailor your mama
wants you dead then he gave blood a grin
the hulking swordsman slew jahari's
instead striking off the boy's head with
a single blow Helena began to scream it
might be strange to say but the men were
true to their word they did no further
harm to Helena or her surviving children
but rather fled with jairus's head in
hand a heel and a cry went up but she's
knew where to run and hide while the
guards did not and The Killers made
their escape only days later blood was
seized at the Gate of the Gods as he was
about to leave King's Landing with the
head of jehairy's hidden in one of the
saddle sacks after he was tortured he
later confessed that he was taking the
boy's head to harrenhal to collect his
reward from Damon Targaryen he also gave
up a description of the [ __ ] he claimed
had hired them an older woman with a
foreign voice who wore a hood over her
head the other harlots named her misery
also known as massaria the White Worm
after 13 days of Hell blood was at last
allowed to die Alison had commanded
Lara's clubfoot to learn his real name
so that she might bathe in the blood of
his wife and children but her sources do
not say if that actually happened sir
Luther largely in the city watch
searched all over the street of silk and
then everywhere throughout King's
Landing but they did not find cheese or
the white worm in his grief and fury
King aegon demanded that all the city's
rat catchers be taken out and hanged and
this was done although bloody and cheese
had spared her life Helena cannot be
said to have survived that fateful night
afterwards she would not eat nor bathe
nor leave her room and she could no
longer stand to look upon her son mailor
knowing she had named him to die aegon
had no other option but to take mailor
and give him over to his mother Alison
for her to raise as her own aegon and
his wife Helena slept separately
thereafter Helena sank deeper and deeper
into madness while aegon drank enraged
and drank this is what we will see
happen after Damon and renera find out
lucari's valerion died at the hands of
aemond one eye and his formidable she
Dragon Veigar